Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, es gibt gute Nachrichten, soll ich dir mal die aktuellen Downloadzahlen der letzten Folge zuschicken?
Ja Moment, ich schalte mal kurz mein Fax-Gerät an.
Buchnetz Politik Nummer dreihundertsechsundachtzig vom zweiundzwanzigsten März zwanzig einundzwanzig und ja es äh gab ein bisschen Echo auf die letzte Sendung. Ist dir das auch aufgefallen?
Ist dir aufgefallen, Tim, auf was ist dich eigentlich fragen wollte, brauchst du noch Masken?
Äh du äh hast du welche?
Ja, also sechs Euro kannst du eine haben.
Ah echt, das ist ja günstig.
Ey, das ist, ich kann nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht mehr Tim. Nee, ich kann nicht mehr.
Kannst schon nicht mehr. Du weißt, dass wir wir müssen noch bis zum Schluss können können. Ja.
Wir müssen noch können, ne? Aber ich kann nicht mehr. Ich kann nicht mehr. Äh und es ist alles so schmerzhaft.
Wie viel hast du? Weißt du die aktuellen Zahlen, wie viele CDUler jetzt wegen Korruption da irgendwie einen Kotau machen mussten?
Nee, aber ich habe so Listen rumgehen sehen und da waren deutlich mehr drauf, als ich dachte. Also, es war eher so äh schon so im zweistelligen Bereich.
Was unter.
Und Söder stellt sich jetzt an die Spitze und will da jetzt irgendwie so geht's ja hier nicht und wir wir brauchen den Ehrenkodex, ne. Also das ist wirklich eine so ein ruinierter Laden, ja so so ein
so eine, also geballte Inkompetenz mit geballter Korruption, das ist wirklich richtig ekelig. Also.
Ist doch schön, dass ihr auch mal die Felle davonschwimmen sehen schon seit längerem.
Ich weiß aber jetzt wenigstens vor, wofür BRD steht. Bananenrepublik Deutschland.
Okay, das war jetzt nicht so äh kreativ.
Okay, war nicht so kreativ, aber mir fällt nichts mehr dazu ein. Weißt du, erstmal hast du von den ganzen CDU-Abgeordneten, die alle schön erst mal die eigene Tasche wirtschaften und dann hast du den Jens Spahn, der sich von EY auf,
idealo googeln lässt, was wohl eine FFP zwei Maske kostet.
Und die dann sagt, ach ja, alles klar, ach so, wenn ich vier Euro kosten, dann lass mal sechs glattmachen, weil die Apotheken haben ja auch Arbeit damit, die auszugeben,
und am Ende hast du eine Situation, dass die Apothekenschilder auf die Straße stellen und sagen, ey, wenn ihr noch so ein wenn ihr noch so einen Gutschein habt, ne, vergesst bitte nicht, uns denen zu geben.
Das ist doch ein einzelner, ein einzelner Apotheker macht hundertsiebzigtausend Euro Profit im Dezember.
Das war noch mal einer, die Wirtschaft steht still.
Die haben den Faktor, je nachdem wie du rechnest, Faktor vier bis fünf, zu vier bezahlt. Das heißt, wir hätten einfach mal vier bis fünf Mal so viele Masken für das gleiche Geld an die Menschen verteilen können.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das eigentliche Problem.
Neun Millionen äh Druckkosten für diese Fälschsicherheitsgutscheine bei der bei der Bundesdruckerei. Das wären allein irgendwie sechs Millionen Masken gewesen, ne?
Einfach große Kisten kaufen auf auf die Straße stellen, fertig.
Ja, es ist, ich find's unerklärlich, es ist unerklärlich. Ich kann da auch nicht mehr. Ich kann das nicht mehr.
Milliarden verschenkt an Apotheken. Weißt du, es gibt so ein paar, die haben echt keine Probleme in der Pandemie. Apotheken gehören dazu.
Mhm. Stimmt's.
Und den schiebst du dann noch ein paar Milliarden vorne und hinten rein und die wissen gar nicht mehr, was sie sich noch für ein für ein Auto kaufen sollen. Was für ein Missmanagement, was für eine, was für eine absolute Katastrophe. Ehrlich.
Ja
Das ist äh sehr verbreitet. Wenn's mal wenn's mal nur das wäre, dann dann dann wäre ich ja zufrieden, so. So ein bisschen Korruption und und und Fehlplanung nebenbei. Da kann ich irgendwie noch mit klarkommen, wenn der Rest irgendwie funktioniert, aber das ist ja leider auch nicht der Fall.
Jetzt haben sie sich irgendwie wochenlang irgendwie einen daran aufgegeilt.
Was ihr jetzt für geile Lockerungsübungen machen treten sich damit den ganzen Quatsch wieder ein.
Da würde ich korrigiert. Ich habe, ich habe ja getwittert, wenn es doch bloß irgendjemand gewarnt hätte, dass Lockerungen exponentielles Wachstum ähm einleiten würden.
Und da hat mich jemand zu zurecht zurechtgewiesen, sagte so, er hört den ganzen Tag nur Lockerungen. Das heißt einfach, äh Auflösung der Seuchenschutzmaßnahmen,
So und das finde ich finde ich wirklich, das sollte man mal langsam ein bisschen mehr es ist wirklich zum Heulen, macht wenig Spaß.
Ja. Also machen wir heute mal nicht so eine lustige Sendung.
Nein, wir dürfen ja auch nicht lustig sein. Wir wurden ja zurechtgewiesen, wir mögen bitte äh keine Witze machen über you burg, so heißt es Unternehmen nämlich. Wurde ich, wurde ich, wurde ich auch zurechtgewiesen.
Ja. Hm.
Die einem dabei helfen, einen ganz guten ähm
Unternehmensnamen oder auch ein Produktnamen zu finden, ne? Die kann man in Anspruch nehmen. Es gibt ja so klassische so klassische Fehler, die andere gemacht haben bei der Benennung ihrer Produkte. Ne, also
kennst du noch den Mitsubishi Pagero.
Ja, das Auto.
Genau und heißt in, irgendwie, ich glaube, Lateinamerika heißt das halt Wichser.
Die haben das Autowichser genannt. Und ähm in bestimmten Ländern heißt Ex äh ist irgendwie ein Synonym für Pimmel. Das Deo hat sich auch nicht so gut verkauft, ne? Und zu solchen Leuten gehst du,
wenn du sagst, wir wollen hier ein, wir wollen eine Firma benennen oder ein Produkt, ne? Und wenn,
Wenn die dich zurückrufen und deinen Namen, deinen Firmennamen nicht richtig aussprechen können, ne? Dann ist das schon mal so ein erstes vorsichtiges Zeichen.
Aber wenn schon die großen Unternehmen das nicht hinbekommen. Ich meine, die Automobilindustrie hat dort nix gelernt. Ich meine, äh Audi bringt ein Auto raus, das heißt e-tron.
Das heißt auf Französisch ist schon viel wie Scheißehaufen. Kein Witz.
Jetzt korrektes Naving.
Zu viel versprechen.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn wenn euer Firmenname nicht aussprechbar ist, dann bestraft ihr nicht die Leute, die das falsch aussprechen, sondern dann bestraft ihr eure euer Marketing, die sich irgendwie in kack ausgedacht haben oder nicht verhindert.
Weißt du übrigens, Tim, wie meine Matratze heißt, kein Scherz, ist eine Ikea Matratze. Die habe ich bei dem Namen auf jeden Fall gekauft. Die heißt Hammerfick.
Konnte ich natürlich nicht dran vorbeigehen.
Linus.
Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Oh Gott, also aber alles eingerissen hier, schon ganz zum Start wieder. Ja.
Nun mal, ich kann doch.
Leute, also Vorsicht im Namensverkehr, das kann schnell dahinten losgehen. Aber vielleicht war das ja auch Absicht. Hut raus.
Ich habe die mit Absicht gekauft,
so dass im Grunde komme mal ein bisschen ähm zum Feedback. Äh wir haben ja nochmal so ein kleines Gespräch auf Klapphaus gemacht. In Zukunft.
Bessere Plattformen finden. Wir haben schon mehrere empfohlen bekommen, wo dann weniger.
Menschen ausgeschlossen sein werden, da sind wir weiterhin in der Suche und auf der Planung und auch Twitter wird potenziell so etwas bald äh anbieten, also habt da noch etwas Geduld mit uns.
Da habe ich ja meine Zweifel.
Ja, aber es gibt äh hier dieses ähm wir haben in den Kommentaren auch nochmal eine andere Plattform empfohlen bekommen, die zumindest äh das von der von der.
Von der Kapazität leisten soll, die schauen wir uns auch nochmal an.
Also was wir in der letzten Sendung nicht erwähnt hatten, waren welche Blockchains überhaupt da Anwendung finden. Äh da gibt es äh verschiedene Blockchains, äh die heißen,
oder ich denke mal, dass ausgesprochen wird. Äh,
dann drei auf Epherienbasierte Blockchains namens Blocksberg Gof Digital und Ephere Classic.
Das sind die äh Blockchains, die da zum Einsatz kommen soll.
Alle für alle fünf.
Alle fünf. Ähm und da kommen wir aber gleich noch mit dem Kommentar zu und dann ja ich denke, ne, ein,
Eine App mit 'nem eingebauten Vertrauensanker ist die einzige sinnvolle Möglichkeit so etwas zu machen
Ich habe mir im Rahmen meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit viele so browserbasierte Systeme angeschaut und solange es nur browserbasiert ist, wirst du da halt einfach nichts seriöses hinbekommen können, weil du immer die.
Letztendlich die Angriffsmöglichkeit hast, dass der Browser dir das Sicherheitsversprechen nicht validiert, was du da hast oder dass du einfach auf einer anderen Seite bist und es nicht merkst. Und äh ja, das,
kann halt nichts werden. Auf äh ist vom vom Paradigma falsch, wenn du äh das äh nur in einem Browser abbilden möchtest.
Dann wurden wir zurechtgewiesen. Tim hat ja in der letzten Sendung verlangt, äh dass wir einen Rapper bräuchten, der gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist und da müssen wir uns äh also haben wir,
das ist MCS T, ja, das hätten wir nicht vergessen dürfen, den haben wir auch glaube ich,
schon bei uns in der in dem Blogbuch als Outro gehabt. Ähm.
MCS T, der hat einen äh Werbevertrag mit Eventphone, den äh dem Team, was immer das,
Telefonie-Netz auf den CCC Events stellt und die haben beim Camp zwanzigneunzehn ihre Vorratsdaten sehr medienwirksam zerstört.
Das war übrigens in der Freakshow äh untergebracht. Hier haben wir es, glaube ich, nicht gespielt. Ja, ja.
Ach so, war das denn in der? Ah, ich bin mir sicher, dass wir das auch referenziert hätten.
Moment, wo ich versucht habe, dieses Video irgendwie in der Sendung abzuspielen und es scheiterte auf allen äh erdenklichen Ebenen.
Stimmt das, der das weiß ich noch. Ja, jedenfalls das Video in den Links und auch die das Beschwerdevideo von MSIST,
findet ihr in den.
So, denn noch weiteres Feedback. Hauke schreibt uns zu der Idee also ich habe ja grob mal skizziert, wie man so etwas machen könnte.
Ähm und habe dann gesagt, so als Anker könnte man einfach was zum Beispiel die letzten Zeichen der Ausweisnummer nehmen, dann sagt Hauke
in Response darauf. Ich mache mir eher Gedanken, dass der Perso gegebenenfalls früher abläuft, als der ganze Corona-Schlamase vorbei ist,
Vielleicht müsste man daher eher die ersten zwei Buchstaben von Vor und Nachnamen und das
Geburtsdatum nehmen, wäre natürlich dichter an der Person, aber wenn man seinen Perso zeigen muss, gegebenenfalls in der Praxis gar nicht so dramatisch. Ich höre immer gerne zu, danke für den Podcast. Ja, danke Marokko. Ähm.
Wenn es so ist, dass sich die Personalausweisnummer ändert, wenn man einen neuen Personalausweis bekommt, ja, dann muss das natürlich äh anders der Bezug zu den persönlichen Daten hergestellt werden. Hast du Recht,
Dann haben wir zu dem ganzen Thema Blockchain einen etwas längeren Kommentar von exzellent Blockchain.
Und äh den lese ich einfach mal äh vollständig vor. Die Sinnhaftigkeit einer oder fünf Blockchains wie von,
Habt ihr in der Sendung, denke ich, sehr gut dargestellt. Ich bin selbst von dem Blockchain Hype überhaupt nicht überzeugt, ich habe danach
jedoch mit ein paar Blockchain begeisterten Menschen diskutiert und dabei tatsächlich eine mögliche, sinnvolle Anwendung von Blockchain gefunden, die jedoch wenig mit dem System von New Work zu tun hat
welche ich technisch ganz spannend finde und hier kurz darstellen möchte, auch als Gegensatz zu den ganzen Bullshit Blockchain, die man sonst so findet. Ihr habt in der Sendung ja bereits das einfache System bestehend aus Daten mit Signaturen auf QR-Code plus Ausweis vorgestellt
Ein Problem an dem Ansatz ist ja doch, wie erkennt man Missbrauch, wenn also zum Beispiel eine bestimmte Impfstelle viel zu viele Signaturen erstellt?
Wenn man dies als Problem sieht, dann benötigt man etwas Ähnliches wie das,
SSL-Zertifikaten. Nun könnte man hierfür natürlich einfach die öffentliche Beglaubigungs API bestellen,
bereitstellen, wo ausgestellte Zertifikate registriert werden müssen, natürlich nur ein hash, der Inhalt sollte nicht an diese Stelle gesendet werden. Das Betreiben solch einer API ist in einer Behörde jedoch vermutlich mit erheblichem Aufwand verbunden
An die Stelle dieser API könnte nun eine existierende Blockchain treten, auf der die Zertifikat-Sessions veröffentlicht werden
Am besten eignen sich hier Blockchains die Proof of Stake verwenden und eine relativ geringe Menge an. Haben. Zum Beispiel kostenlosbasierte Blockchain,
Bei solchen chayns muss kein mathematisches Rätsel gelöst werden, sondern es reicht, eine Zertifizierung des Blocks von zwei Drittel der Velle Datas. Ein Beweis über solch eine Zertifizierung könnte dann in dem QR-Code gespeichert werden und,
offline verifiziert werden. Es müsste nur regelmäßig eine Synchronisation der aktuellen, dies ist jedoch nicht für jede einzelne Überprüfung notwendig. Im Kern wird hier die Blockchain also dazu verwendet, ein öffentliches Log
der von einer Impfstelle ausgestellten Zertifikate zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Der Hauptvorteil liegt darin, dass man existierende Infrastruktur in Form von bereits existierenden Blockchains verwenden kann, um dieses Lok kryptographisch sicher zur Verfügung zu stellen und nicht extra eigene Services betreiben muss.
Ähm,
Also die die Frage, ne, das Risiko wäre also hier, du hast eine bösartige Zertifizierungsstelle, die einfach ohne Ende Impfnachweise ausstellt oder Test-Nachweise ausstellt, ohne tatsächlich durchgeführt zu haben.
Ähm ja, ich denke trotzdem, dass man das eleganter lösen könnte, indem du ähm zum Beispiel den,
auf der niedrigsten Ebene, den Zertifizierungsstellen nicht das Schlüsselmaterial zum Ausstellen von,
validen äh oder Testnachweisen in die Hand gibst, sondern zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt hier demnächst sollen ja die Hausärztinnen mit vierzig Impfungen pro Woche.
Arbeiten, den willst du ja nicht allen notwendigerweise wirklich Kimaterial geben und dann gibst du denen vielleicht einfach eine API, wo sie die Daten hinschicken und die ähm,
designierten Infoausweise zurückbekommen und dabei halt darauf geachtet wird, dass es nur so viele, dass sie nur so viele ausstellen können, wie sie auch Impfungen haben oder so. Also auch da denke ich nicht, dass du eine Blockchain bräuchtest, vor allem weil du dann eben,
in dem Moment, wo die Impfstelle wird, hättest du ja eh schon die ähm.
Den Schlamassel, weil du dann nicht mehr wüsstest, welche valide sind und welche nicht. Also müsstest du eigentlich das Frühjahr unterbinden.
Als dass du es nachher feststellen kannst.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine, in dem Kommentar wird ja auch angenommen, es sei jetzt sehr Behörde nicht zuzumuten, so eine Revocation RPI äh zu betreiben
weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das äh wirklich so ist. Ich finde, dass man das sehr wohl äh äh einer Behörde sowas zumuten kann
weil da jetzt irgendwie auch keine besondere Komplexität drinsteckt, zumindest äh ist jetzt die Komplexität mit den Blockchains auch nicht anders. Und wenn man sich auf dritte Blockchains.
Bezieht, ja, dann ist das ja auch immer alles mit der Annahme verbunden, dass die auf Ewigkeiten funktionieren. So und was ist, wenn die nicht funktionieren? Also das.
Hast du noch vier andere. Aber, aber die, die Sache ist tatsächlich die ähm.
Auch dieser Blockchain-Ansatz ändert ja nichts daran, dass irgendjemand auf das auf den Missbrauch monitoren und entsprechend dann revoken muss.
Und das kannst du am Ende tatsächlich diese eine Sache würde ich tatsächlich natürlich zentral machen mit der haust du die Revocations raus und dann kannst du nämlich.
Die potentiell einzelne äh Revoken oder eben auch ganze Intermediaries, dann können die sind von denen alle äh alle ungültig, die sie signiert haben. Also das sind doch schon gelöste Probleme.
Ja und vor allem, was was mich wirklich nachhaltig an dieser ganzen Debatte um Blockchains immer wieder stört, ist so. Die ganze Argumentation ist, Leute strengen sich enorm an.
Um irgendwie eine Lösung dafür zu finden, wie man dann doch trotz aller Nachteile irgendwie irgendeine Variante von Blockchains benutzen kann und
so denkt man nicht über technische Lösungen nach, sondern man schaut sich an, was das Problem, dann schaut man, was ist sozusagen die einfachste Lösung äh für dieses Problem? Äh die reicht?
So und das das implementiert man dann und denkt nicht immer darüber nach, wie kann ich das jetzt irgendwie mit Blockchains reinmachen, weil es macht ja auch ganz den Eindruck, dass jetzt auch in diesem Fall,
so ein bisschen diese Logik ist, so nach dem Motto ja, wir haben jetzt mal drüber nachgedacht, aber eigentlich brauchen wir gar keine Blockchains, aber irgendjemand ist halt der Meinung
dass es dann irgendwie cooler klingt oder dass man sich irgendeinen use case äh schon irgendwie zusammenreiben kann und gucke mal, dann dann wirkt das doch gleich viel geiler,
Die richtige Notwendigkeit ist einfach nicht da und wenn dann eine Notwendigkeit für ein technisches Detail nicht existiert, dann hat man es wegzulassen, damit man einfach die Komplexität nicht unnötig steigert,
weil das tut man.
Wie ich schon sagte, seitdem mit der Blockchain ein Problem mal gelöst wurde, wollen alle dieses Problem haben. Ansonsten.
Hören wir aus äh anderen Quellen, dass es also hier ja eine,
der von mehreren Leuten wurde der Verdacht genährt in den Kommentaren und von einigen äh nichtöffentlichen Quellen auch grob so in die Richtung gedeutet, dass es ähm,
bei der bei der Blockchain einerseits eben um einen Schutz des zusätzlichen Schutzes Ausstellungsdatums gehen soll und grundsätzlich natürlich die
zentrale Signatur von New Work eben relevant ist, ja klar und,
diesen Blockchain-Kram haben da wohl eher IBM und das äh Gesundheitsministerium reingepresst. Und viele haben uns ja auch darauf hingewiesen.
Das IBM vor ein paar Jahren eine relativ große Blockchain-Sparte, Stolz, gelauncht hat, die dann aber wohl wirtschaftlich keinen Fuß fassen konnte, äh sodass es hier ein bisschen danach riecht, als habe IBM,
hier das Interesse gehabt, seine Blockchain-Sparte unbedingt noch unterzubringen und da, wie ich in der letzten Sendung sagte, IBM,
die einzigen sind, die wahrscheinlich in der Lage sind, so etwas auch Deutschland weit auszurollen, ähm konnten sie darüber natürlich dann auch ihren Blockchain, ihr Blockchain-Team,
reinhebeln. Tja, also das das so zumindest der Flurfunk. Aber,
Blockchains sind Unsinn, wenn man der ausgebenden Stelle traut.
Also äh hätten wir in der letzten Sendung auch noch viel mehr äh IBM mitbashen sollen. Da hätten wir wenigstens auch gewusst, wie man's ausspricht.
So, dann haben wir einen Kommentar zu Kontakt, Kontaktkontaktverfolgung und Quarantäne.
Und zwar, Moment, dieser Kommentar war von.
Yannis. Äh sagt, schickt doch bitte alle Kontaktpersonen in Quarantäne, sonst wird das nichts mit Pandemie und äh und Track-In,
nichts damit die Pandemie mit in den Griff zu bekommen. Ja, darauf habe ich alles geantwortet. Das Problem ist genau das können wir uns gerade nicht leisten, ne? Also dafür ist die Inzidenz zu hoch
und dann würdest du halt die ganze Zeit immer ganz viele Leute ähm,
äh in irgendwelche Quarantänen schicken, die noch dazu für den größeren Teil dieser Leute eben,
unsinnig wären, ne? Es ist ja tatsächlich so, wenn man sich diesen Ehrwert anschaut, es ist ja so, dass im Durchschnitt eine einzelne erkrankte Person relativ wenige weitere ansteckt,
Das heißt, wenn du alle möglichen Kontaktpersonen von dieser infizierten Person äh in Quarantäne setzt, dann wirst du sehr, sehr viele Leute unsinnigerweise in Quarantäne schicken.
Und deswegen kannst du dir das eigentlich nur erlauben,
wenn du niedrige Inzidenzen hast und sagst, pass mal auf, das machen wir hier, ja, das ist drakonisch und ja, ihr werdet jetzt alle äh unsinniger Weise in dieser Quarantäne sitzen. Aber dafür halten wir unsere Inzidenz bei drei.
Und dann trifft das nicht so viele, ja? Und daraufhin antwortete Jiannis dann auch so gesehen,
hat aber doch auch das RKI die Chance verspielt, im letzten Sommer bei sehr niedriger Inzidenz die Quarantäneregeln entsprechend zu überarbeiten und damit einer Herbst-Winter-Welle entgegen zu treten. Dem würde ich mich so anschließend Jannes.
Tim hatte in der letzten Sendung auch nochmal sehr viel dafür plädiert, die Corona-Warn-App im.
Informativen Bereich zu verbessern, also dass sie einem.
Informationen darüber gibt, ne, wie sieht's aus hier deine Reiseplanung? Kannst du durch dieses Land fahren oder nicht, ne? Fliegst du lieber über Mallorca, damit du bei der Rückreise keine,
Quarantäneauflagen hast oder so, ne? Und dazu schrieb uns Patrick,
mir ist aufgefallen, dass in der gesamten Berichtserstattung nicht nur bei euch zu dem Themenkomplex der Corona-Apps, die aus meiner Sicht vielleicht beste App kaum Beachtung findet und selten erwähnt wird. Das mag
darlegen, dass diese App nicht mit großen Tamtam als Neuerungen präsentiert werden konnte, da sich schon seit Jahren zuverlässig ihren Dienst tut. Damit meine ich,
Natürlich die Notfallinformations- und Nachrichten-App des BBK, kurz Nina. Der Premiereeinsatz,
Als Unwetter-Warn-App geplant, doch als ich im letzten Jahr Corona ausbreitete, hat man reagiert
und die sich ankündigende Pandemie im März zwanzig zwanzig aufgenommen, dank der Integration von Google Maps beziehungsweise Apple Maps kann man genaue Informationen zu dem Landkreis Stadtteil erhalten, den man sich aufhält. Zusätzlich können weitere Landkreise angelegt werden
Was ich sehr praktisch fand, da ich beruflich manchmal für einige Tage außerhalb tätig bin. Klar, diese App macht kein contact-Tracing, per Blockchain.
Liefert aber schnell, aktuelle Informationen zu den gerade gültigen sogar direkt nach treffen der Kanzlerin und den Länderchefs beim letzten Mal,
um circa ein Uhr dreißig. Sofern es keine fundamentalen Fails bei dieser App gibt, die wir entgangen sind, kann ich die Nutzung sehr empfehlen.
Ja, ist richtig. Äh das ist auch tatsächlich so eine so eine App, die äh wenig Leute kennen. Ja, was so ein bisschen Teil des Problems ist,
Was viele Leute kennen ist und oft wird Katwaren so als die App wahrgenommen, die eigentlich genau das tut
Ähm wiederum ist allerdings von den großen Versicherungen dieses Landes zusammengebastelt und betrieben und ähm Nina ist halt da die Informationsquelle des Bundes.
Ähm alles richtig und Nina hat natürlich einen einen Vorteil gegenüber der Corona-Warn-App, der,
klar, insofern als dass sie natürlich auf die Location des Telefons zugreifen kann, von daher eben,
gestützte Informationen liefern kann. Meine Erfahrung mit der App, ich habe die auch schon seit Jahren installiert, ist das ein na ja also.
Ich will da jetzt nicht so drüber äh viel reden, da das hat auf jeden Fall viel Verbesserungspotenzial, aber davon haben wir jetzt mal ganz abgesehen, ist es natürlich so,
dass wenn jetzt diese Corona-Regeln für die NINA App so schön aufgearbeitet werden, dann gibt es ja überhaupt gar keinen Grund, die nicht auch einfach in der Corona-Warn-App einfach mit anzuzeigen, so. Ja, also wenn man's dann eh schon,
redaktionell beisammen hat,
dann ist es einfach nur nochmal eine Frage eines eines eines Internetzugriffs und dann kann man diese Informationen selbstverständlich auch in der CWA einbringen. Ganze Sinn dieser ganzen Debatte war ja, wie kann man eben die Corona-Warn-App noch interessanter machen
und ähm alles,
was man an Nutzen sozusagen, klar, man hat immer das Problem, dann wird die App zu kompliziert, lalala, also das hat ist auch ein valider Punkt und muss man dann im Design richtig äh unterkriegen, aber ich glaube, so die aktuelle Warnlage mit Anzeigen et cetera
Und ähm äh auf Wunsch dann auch noch die Regeln einblenden, ist jetzt auch echt nicht zu viel verlangt und das würde auch sicherlich diese App nicht äh komplett überlasten, zumal es eben hochgradig relevant ist in dem Moment.
Ich habe die gerade mal runtergeladen. Uiuiuiui, wir sind also ja ja, ich kann hier auf jeden Fall genau.
Population, Cases und so weiter angucken. Interessant, ja? Das ist äh.
Allerdings fragt Patrick Patrick auch ob wir irgendwelche Probleme mit der App haben. Ist das nicht die, die so katastrophal gefällt hat, als sie irgendwie diesen Notfall-Warntag machen wollten und die alle auf einmal auslösen wollten und dann festgestellt haben, ja, klappte gar nicht.
Weil sie eben hier ein IP-basiertes äh Massenkommunikationswahnsignal senden wollten, statt mal halt auf Sell-ID zu setzen.
Ja, müsste.
Entschuldigung.
Müsste sie eigentlich gewesen sein. Ich wollte ihnen das jetzt gerade nicht so richtig zusammen, was da falsch war, ja, aber das.
Ja, wir haben's versprochen. Die haben, die haben's einfach nicht hingekriegt, ne. Also ist auch nicht ist auch nicht verwunderlich, dass du halt, äh, wenn du, wenn dein Ziel ist, viele Millionen Bürgerinnen in Sekundenschnelle zu alarmieren, das hat halt schiefgeht,
einem IP-basierten Verfahren. Dafür hast du eben diese äh Broadcast äh EU-Standards gibt's da ja auch, die wir umsetzen müssten.
Aber da hatte doch äh vor ein paar Monaten gab's da einen größeren größeren äh ich glaube sogar mit Rücktritten und so beim BBK.
Aber das ist etwas anderes. So, damit sind wir so ein bisschen mit dem Feedback durch und kommen zum ersten Thema,
Und zwar dieses Thema, ereilte mich während wir die letzte Sendung aufzeichneten,
kam dann so ein Chat ploppte auf und sagte Linus, hm, wir haben da was, ich glaube, du musst uns mal helfen.
Wir haben da mal wieder was kaputt gemacht.
Und dann habe ich nach der Sendung mich zurückgemeldet, gesagt, okay, was habt ihr diesmal? Und zwar waren das die Leute von der Zerforschung, die haben in Berlin einen Corona-Schnelltest gemacht. Die werden ja jetzt hier,
kostenlos angeboten und da hat äh das Land Berlin offenbar ein Labor berechtigt, das zu tun.
Und das ist äh das wird betrieben von einundzwanzig DX, irgendwie so ein sehr kürzlich gegründetes Unternehmen, was äh eben Corona-Testzentren als Pop-Up-Stores betreibt und sich selber als die größte,
Betreiberin von Corona-Teststellen in Deutschland bezeichnet.
Und jetzt ist das so, ne, wie gesagt, diese Teststellen, das sind eigentlich ja, so Pop-Up Stores, ne, wenn man in einem war, da gehst du rein, da sitzt dann irgendeine halbwegs gelangweilte Studentin oder so, ne,
klickt auf den Computer rum und steckt ihr dann da halt den Stab rein und dann kriegst du äh danach,
über einen QR-Code kannst du dann halt das Ergebnis abholen, kannst irgendwo hingehen und sagen, ja hier kriegst du halt so einen kannst ein PDF runterladen. So und diese.
Die Softwarelösung quasi für ein solches ähm Impfsystem.
Er hat ein Wiener Unternehmen mit dem Namen Medicus AI bereitgestellt und safe play genannt. Die machen also im Prinzip von der Terminbuchung,
bis zum Onlinetest Zertifikat alles in einem Rutsch. Und ein Mitglied von der Zerforschung hat halt oder zwei Mitglieder von der Zerforschung haben halt an dem Tag mal einen Corona-Schnelltest gemacht.
Und haben sich dann ihr ähm Ergebnis abgeholt. Und ich fasse es jetzt mal vereinfacht zusammen. Das war so, dass sie dann irgendwie quasi die URL, wo dein Testergebnis liegt, ist ungefähr so etwas wie,
einundzwanzig DX Punkt medicus AI Schrägstrich Testergebnis,
fünfhundertachtzig, ja? Und wenn du dann halt sagst, ach, ich hätte aber lieber gerne Testergebnis fünfhundertneunundachtzig, dann kriegst du halt das Testergebnis von jemand anderem. Und dieses Testergebnis von der anderen Person.
Beinhaltet, weil die ja diese Dinger immer als Nachweise bauen wollen. Die Ausweisnummer, Adresse, Telefonnummer, Testergebnis ähm und so weiter von der Person, die sich da hat testen lassen.
Selbstverständlich sollte das nicht so sein, dass du die Testergebnisse von anderen Personen inklusive ihrer kompletten personenbezogenen Daten einsehen kannst.
Und erst recht nicht, allein in diesem einzelnen Fall von einhundertsechsunddreißigtausend anderen Tests,
ja? Die insgesamt äh also nicht nur die Tests waren
hoch und runterzählbar aufzufinden, sondern auch die jeweils die Betroffenen, also die getesteten Personen konntest du quasi auch auf diese Weise eh nummerieren, da waren's nur äh etwas über achtzigtausend, das heißt,
Offenbar haben viele Personen schon mehrmals dort Tests gemacht, ne? Also ungefähr achtzigtausend Personen, hundertsechsunddreißigtausend Tests.
Bei dieser einen Plattform von dieser einen Testzentrum Betreiberin einundzwanzig TX, die eben mehrere in Berlin äh,
macht von den Massenteststellen, aber da waren dann auch so kleinere temporäre Einrichtungen oder sowas, ne? Von Unternehmen äh von Kitas, von Schulen, teilweise auch nur so Pop-Up, einen Tag mal Teststationen, das war da alles äh,
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Haben wir schön gemacht, haben wir wieder ein wunderschönes Beispiel für Digitalisierung von irgendwelchen voll,
Spezialexperten, die noch nicht einmal wissen, dass man eben solche kritischen Daten einfach nicht einfach innummerierbar macht und dass man selbstverständlich prüfen muss, ob eine Person die Testergebnisse einzieht, auch berechtigt ist, dieses spezifische Testergebnis einzusehen.
Also es ist wirklich äh äh Schockierend. Ich meine, wir wir reden, wir reden hier nicht von komplexen Security-Anforderungen
und so Race Conditions, wo dann so oh, hast du mal darüber nachgedacht und so, sondern das ist das totale One One, was man auch schon vor zehn Jahren eigentlich um die Ohren geknallt
hat, vom anderen. Und da muss man sagen, dann nicht sichtlich äh äh wundern, wenn dann so äh Random Hacker Group vorbeikommt und sagt äh
Wir haben mal dreiundzwanzig Sekunden aufgewendet, um das genauer anzuschauen und dann ist irgendwie alles auseinander geflossen.
Ja, total. Also und,
dummerweise, das ist ja nicht nur da der Fall, ne? Du hast ja bei den äh irgendwie bei den Alditests geht's genauso, ja, da da konntest du auch irgendwie dir dann dein Test-Zertifikat manipulieren. Konntest du übrigens beim Medicus AI auch, ne? Du konntest dir quasi,
im Nachhinein einfach deine Daten ändern und für jemand anders ein Testzertifikat ausstellen lassen. Was jetzt.
Was einfach nur sehr komfortabel ist, weil ich meine, streng genommen kannst du dir auch einfach das PDF runterladen und mit jedem Editan einen anderen Namen reinschreiben, ne. Also, das mal ganz ohnehin.
Aber also wirklich Software in katastrophalem ähm.
Katastrophaler Qualität. Und da muss man sich echt mal anschauen, also diese Testzentren, ne,
Als ich meine ersten Corona-Schnelltest irgendwie letztes Jahr besorgt habe, ne, zu Apothekenpreisen. Da waren die ähm bei irgendwo elf, zwölf Euro im ähm Retail, ne, also,
geringe Menge Tests gekauft in einer Apotheke. So,
Wenn du inzwischen, sind die, ne, was ist das? Irgendwo beim Fünfer, wenn du bei Aldi welche bekommst? Ungefähr, ne? Und ähm.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie die, ja, die Guten haben willst, dann bist du vielleicht irgendwo bei sowas wie sieben Euro. Ja, aber immer Retail-Preise. So. Und diese Testzentren,
die sich natürlich Hold Sale, das heißt die kaufen nicht irgendwie zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig, fünfzig Stück, sondern die kaufen natürlich direkt hunderte oder Tausende, ne? Heißt, die kriegen natürlich auch nochmal ganz andere Preise. Und bieten dir so einen Test an.
Für vierzig Euro.
Das ist schon relativ, also das ist relativ profitabel, dieses Schnelltest-Business. Und ich bin mal gespannt, ich will gar nicht wissen, was der Jens Spahn, den ich jetzt für Kohle zahlt, wenn er sagt, einen könnte er die Woche kostenlos machen, ne?
Ich will nicht wissen, ob der Jens, was die Berater von Jens Spahn da wieder gegoogelt haben, ne, also das kann auch nochmal gefährlich werden. Ähm also das ist echt eine das ist wirklich eine eine schnelle Geldnummer hier und da kannst
klar, da wird dann von irgendeiner windigen Softwarebude äh schnell was äh
gestrickt, wenn du die wenn du die das Unternehmen mal googelst äh oder auf LinkedIn suchst, das habe ich natürlich gemacht auf der Suche nach einem Weg, die zu kontaktieren, findest du,
Ja, wie soll man das sagen? Ein sehr.
Internationales Team, das sich offenbar auch äh jeweils international aufhält. Das ist nicht schlecht,
So, das nicht unbedingt schlimm, dass das,
Team über den Globus verteilt ist, die können ja irgendwie über Zoom konferieren, aber das macht eben auch nicht den Eindruck, dass das eben ein Team ist, was die gemeinsame Arbeit,
schon sehr lange pflegt oder auf eine irgendeine Tradition oder so zurückblickt und entsprechend war halt auch eben hier die Qualität,
Ergebnisses. Na ja, was haben wir gemacht? Wir haben dann,
ähm gedacht, also einmal habe ich gedacht, okay, lasst uns einfach mal alle Daten runterladen, damit sie nicht nachher behaupten, es werden nicht alle Daten runtergeladen worden. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, naja
pass auf, was willst du mit hundertsechsunddreißigtausend Coronatests auf deinem Computer? Dann hast du halt die Sorge, die wieder loszuwerden und ähm
Ja, es entspricht halt nicht dem dem ethischen Anspruch, sich alle diese Daten untern Nagel zu reißen. Also haben wir
gesagt, wir machen das ganz anders. Wir kontaktieren das BSI, haben äh übern,
Kontakt den BSI Bescheid gegeben, beim BSI gibt es eine Corona-Task-Force, wusste ich auch nicht, aber weil halt gerade alle so flott ihre Softwareschrott zusammenstricken, muss das BSI eine eigene Einheit dafür bereit halten.
Ja äh ja immer, ne, ist traurig, dass es nötig ist, aber schön, dass das BSI das macht. Und ähm das hat auch hier sehr schnell gewirkt, ne? Also das BSI hat die den Befund validiert,
das Unternehmen kontaktiert und die Behebung der Schwachstelle hat dann auch sehr zügig stattgefunden. Zur Sicherheit haben wir dann noch,
in den verschiedenen Ländern, von denen wir festgestellt haben, dass dieses System benutzt wird, auch an die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten und an den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten gemeldet. Ähm wir haben dann noch durch eine äh Recherche,
Ein paar andere Testzentren Betreiber gefunden, die auch dieses System nutzen, ne, also dieses Medicus AI Safe Play wird quasi unterschiedlichen,
Testzentren verkauft und unter den jeweils einer von Medicus AI betrieben. Das heißt, es waren noch sehr viel mehr betroffen, als diese,
hundertdreißigtausend, die wir jetzt nur bei einundzwanzig TX gefunden haben.
Ja und dann passiert genau das, nämlich dass das Unternehmen ähm sagt, ja, wunderbar, äh wir können einen massenhaften Zugriff ausschließen und deswegen müssen wir auch nicht alle Nutzerinnen informieren, sondern nur die paar, auf die jetzt hier,
Forschung und CCC zugegriffen haben.
Ja, diese, ja.
Weißt du? Und das finde ich halt auch.
Ich, also die, die Argumentation überlasse ich anderen, ja, dafür haben wir die ja auch den den äh Datenschutzbeauftragten gemeldet, ja, die wissen,
ähm die wissen, das zu beurteilen, wie die rechtliche Situation ist,
Da mische ich mich nicht ein, aber es ist halt, weißt du so, dieses typische, ja, es ist ja nichts passiert, ne. Es gibt die Betroffenen, es ist eine geringe Anzahl an Betroffenen. Nein, es sind halt viele Tausende Betroffene, die ihr.
Da in dieses System reingeprügelt bekommen habt und dann fing sie auch noch an und sagten, ja, aber die zu informieren wäre nicht ihre Pflicht, weil sie sind ja nur Auftragsdatenverarbeitende, von den Impfzentren, für die sie diese Plattform betreiben.
Spätestens dann weißt du wirklich bei wem du da gelandet bist, ne? Wenn die dann auch noch ja sagen wir mal nicht aufrichtig damit umgehen wollen oder versuchen das,
Problem klein zu halten,
fand ich insgesamt relativ schockierend und ja, es ist leider immer so, ne, dass oder häufig so, deswegen hatte ich ja eingangs auch den Punkt und habe gesagt,
Eigentlich müsste man jetzt mal echt alles runterladen, damit die sich nachher nicht da rausreden. Ähm aber.
Lassen wir das.
Ja, war auf jeden Fall mal, kann ich mal was positives über das BSI sagen? Die haben da ähm zügig die Sache geklärt und äh ja, wir haben als äh CCC dann eine Veröffentlichung draus gemacht. Zur Forschung hat ähm.
Auch einen Post, wo sie's viel mehr technische Details halt auch beschreiben und weil das Unternehmen in Wien ansässig ist, haben wir da auch noch,
sofort mit Thomas Lohninger,
zusammengearbeitet von EpiCenter Works, ne? Kennen ja hier unsere Zuhörerinnen, die hat dann quasi die Meldung in Österreich an das und so übernommen, um da,
an der entsprechenden Stelle für zügige Umsetzung zu sorgen. Hat Spaß gemacht, war lustig, aber,
Es ist halt also was der Moment, in dem du auf so was Zugriff kriegst, ist halt auch echt immer schockierend, weil du dir denkst, ne, scheiße, wenn das jetzt schon andere haben.
Und natürlich dir auch überlegen musst, so okay, wie kriegst du, wie kriegst du's schnell behoben? Und du hast natürlich auch immer,
gewisses äh Risiko, ne, dass die vielleicht nicht fair spielen wollen und versuchen, die irgendwie,
an die Karre zu fahren. Deswegen haben wir in dem Fall dann auch gesagt, nee, da schreibe ich jetzt nicht, was ich üblicherweise in solchen Situationen mache ich ja sehr, sehr häufig. Meist entspreche ich da auch gar nicht großartig drüber.
Kleinere Fälle sind, dann schreibst du halt eine freundliche Mail, sagst hallo, hier CCC, ich wollte nur eben Bescheid sagen.
Und ähm aber in diesem Fall haben wir dann gesagt, nee, das äh müssen wir mal, müssen wir mal den BSI geben und die als Proxi davor schalten.
Ja, das ist er auch wieder so etwas, was immer so ein Vertrauensproblem dann wieder so mit sich äh bringt, ne? Und.
Muss dann so ein so ein Laden halt auch einfach bringen. Das ist relativ wichtig. Krisen
ziehen dann auch immer schnell so Akteure äh an Start, die dann schnelles Geld sehen
Vielleicht durchaus auch, sagen wir mal in einem Bereich äh agieren, in dem äh Not am Mann ist, wo wirklich auch was getan werden muss. Das gilt ja zum Beispiel auch für diese Schnelltests an sich, ne.
Nur jetzt hast du halt irgendwie auch solche,
die dann irgendwie sagen, so ja, dann kaufen wir jetzt mal hier so einen Lastwagen voll mit Schnelltest und dann stellen wir uns mal schön in die Fußgängerzone und machen da so unsere Schnelltests
Ja, dann haben sie dann halt diese Schnelltests irgendwie bei minus vier Grad so draußen aufm Tisch stehen und wenn du dir mal die Packungsbeilage durchliest, dann steht da sowas wie,
Erstmal auf Raumtemperatur bringen und so, weißt du?
Funktioniert das gar nicht. Und das sind einfach so so Security-Anforderungen. Es gilt halt nicht nur im Digitalen, sondern halt auch im medizinischen und operativen, die müssen dann auch einfach äh gerade geklopft werden.
Also man ist schon erstaunt, was eben diese Pandemie eben auch für geschäftstüchtige.
An ob's an Möglichkeiten bietet, ne? Das werden dann halt mal eben zügig.
Testzentren hoch, Testzentren, Betreiberinnen hochgezogen, die werden dann mit den Software gezimmert. Auf eine Weise ist das ja auch nicht schlecht. Also es ist ja gut, wenn ähm ja, allgemein die Möglichkeit besteht,
So etwas schnell hochgezogen wird und halt Leute, die Software schreiben, die Plattform bauen, damit Leute, die,
Ja, deren Qualifikation im Prinzip ist, Schnelltests zu kaufen und ähm.
Ja und äh irgendwie Studierende da einzustellen, die das durchführen, ja. Ähm,
Damit sowas passiert. Ich finde ja Tests sehr wichtig. Ja, ich will ein großer Fan von Tests, ähm weil sie im Moment das ist, die das beste, der Beste zur Verfügung stehende Weg sind, sich kurze.
Freiräume der Sicherheit ähm zu schaffen,
ja? Und ähm aber ist dann natürlich tragisch, wenn diejenigen, die da die am geschäftstüchtigsten sind, nicht die die Kompetenz mit aufbringen, das einfach mal so umzusetzen, wie sich eben gehört.
Naja, okay. Kommen wir zum Impfpassvorschlag der EU-Kommission, Tim.
Ja, sowas gibt's auch.
Sowas gibt's auch ähm und zwar von äh Ursula, van der Ley, ich komme.
Von der Leyen.
Von der von der Leine.
Ja, da bin ich immer das, weil das Laien so mit Y geschrieben wird, dann denkt man so, ah, vielleicht wird das von auch mit A geschrieben. Okay, Ursula von der Leyen hat ähm.
Bekannt gegeben, dass jetzt also die EU-Kommission einen einen Impfpass vorschlägt und ähm ja.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall nicht ganz so unsinnig, ja. Sie sehen ziemlich genau vor, dass es also eine dezentrale,
signierte Variante gibt, ja, dass also nicht irgendwo eine zentrale Impfdatenbank äh aufgeführt wird oder nicht irgendwo ein zentrales Impfregister geführt wird. Ähm die Bürgerinnen haben,
ähm können auch ein Papierzertifikat bekommen, allerdings haben sie da nicht ein Wahlrecht bei,
ähm wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Ähm.
Oder sie bekommen beides. Das ist mir noch nicht ganz klar. Ähm wenn die WHO den Notstand der Pandemie für beendet erklärt, soll auch dieses System nicht mehr,
aktiv sein. Also sie sagen quasi, solange das ein Notstand ist, machen wir das jetzt, aber dann,
führen wir, machen wir es auch wieder weg. Das nennt man immer so eine Sunset-Claws, ne, also eine eine Sonnenuntergangsklausel,
die bei einem System eben sicherstellt, wir machen das nur so lange, wie wir es auch tatsächlich brauchen. Und das hier an der externe ähm.
Instanz wie die WHO zu binden ist ja erstmal nicht so blöd. Allerdings glaube ich, dass es relativ lange dauern wird, bis die WHO den weltweiten Notstand durch die Pandemie für beendet erklärt, weil ähm.
Erstmal werden ja jetzt so die ganzen.
Länder des globalen Nordens sagt man ja jetzt, glaube ich. Ähm durchgeimpft und dann hast du die Situation natürlich immer noch,
viel länger in den Ländern des globalen Südens, den wir einfach grade keinen Impfstoff geben, ne? Und ähm,
insofern wird sich wird dieses System wahrscheinlich nicht nur einen kurzen Zeitraum. Ähm genutzt werden.
In dem QR-Code wird eben nur eine einzige digitale Signatur gespeichert sein und die wird dann eben von einer zentralen,
Server ins Infrastruktur geprüft werden. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, warum das sein soll, weil man theoretisch auch den CAs einfach vertrauen könnte. Aber ich denke, dass sie dann hier eben mit äh zur äh zur ähm,
Verifikation und zum zum äh,
zum potenziellen Revocation ähm nochmal quasi an der zentralen Infrastruktur haben wollen, wo einfach nur die,
Die Prüfsummen, also die Signaturen von den QR-Codes gesammelt sind, um zu sagen, jo, der ist wirklich echt und ähm.
Wie gesagt, der Schritt ist nicht sollte nicht notwendig sein, aber ich vermute, dass er der Kontrolle dient, dass eben nicht irgendjemand hier über übersigniert.
Aber Linus, da ist ja gar keine Blockchain drin. Kann ja das funktionieren.
Und nicht. Habe ich, hatten wir, glaube ich, geklärt, oder?
Das kommt jetzt sehr überraschend. Das ist doch schön.
So und dann gab es noch ein.
Da sind's natürlich der Nachweis soll keine Voraussetzung für die Bewegungsfreiheit sein und niemanden diskriminieren. Gleichzeitig sagen sie aber,
Was man jetzt für Geimpfte macht und nicht, müssten eben die Mitgliedsstaaten entscheiden.
Und es bleibt eben dabei, dass sie hier eine Diskriminierungsmöglichkeit,
schaffen und sich aber von staatlicher Seite eben mit der Diskriminierung selber nicht die ähm Finger.
Schmutzig machen wollen, ja? Entscheidend ist aber auch hier, ist eine ähm.
Mit den Tests quasi mit drin, ja? Also sie sagen, das soll im, also es wird ein Emulitätsnachweis und nicht ein Impfausweis. Ähm.
Und das äh führt also dazu, dass nicht Geimpfte potenziell eben durch Tests,
ebenfalls mit dem gleichen System auf Sicherheit geprüft werden können. Und das hatte ich ja in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt. Das ist ein sehr entscheidender Faktor,
den ich den ich.
Den ich noch nicht zu Ende gedacht habe, aber den ich eigentlich, an dem ich keinen Nachteil finde, ja, weil wenn du sagst, okay, mit Tests.
Kannst du temporär den gleichen Status wie eine Geimpfte Person erlangen,
und diese Tests werden dir auch zugänglich gemacht. Ähm dann kann das ja wirklich,
diskriminierungsfreier Rehaweg aus der Pandemie sein. Und das klingt,
erstmal ganz sinnvoll, ja? Und potenziell, sofern denn so viele Tests zur Verfügung stünden, könnte man damit natürlich.
Temporäre Freiräume schaffen.
Restaurant nur mit aktuellem Test oder äh Impfnachweis. Das heißt, es gibt ähm für keine Person einen nicht zumutbaren Aufwand,
diese Location betreten zu können, es sei denn, man bleibt dabei, dass man sagt, Test kostet aber vierzig Euro. Ne, damit ihr also
was ja auch wirklich also da, ich weiß nicht, ob die Apotheken sich getraut hätten, sowohl Preise zu nehmen.
Also ich will da mal kurz das Wort diskriminieren äh wird mir ein bisschen zu sehr diskriminiert in diesem Zusammenhang,
Es gibt da immer zwei Bedeutungen, die man, glaube ich, mal klar äh unterscheiden muss. Das eine ist halt das, glaube ich, was die meisten Leute sofort im im Kopf haben, dass es einfach bedeutet, dass man irgendwie jemanden jetzt einen Nachteil verschafft.
Ja? Äh
im Zweifelsfall dann auch noch zu unrecht. Äh man kann das halt aber auch in seinem Wortsinne einfach nur nehmen, dass man diskriminiert im Sinne von, dass man eine,
eine Unterscheidung möglich macht
und darum geht es glaube ich primär, ne? Also es ist halt einfach, du musst einfach Daten haben, anhand dem du äh gepflegte Informationen machen kannst, gerade um zum Beispiel Veranstaltungen durchzusetzen äh oder um umsetzen zu können.
Und ja, da macht äh macht es eben schon äh Sinn, aber es hat natürlich auch andere Probleme, die wir ausführlich jetzt in der letzten Sendung schon diskutiert haben und davor und deswegen brauchen wir das auch nicht zu wiederholen.
Summa summarum, die EU hat auch einen technischen Vorschlag. Am Ende muss sich auch Deutschland damit abfinden in dieses Fremdwork eigentlich reinrutschen zu müssen,
und von daher äh sind diese ganzen Blockchain-Diskussionen insofern eh schon überflüssig, weil das wird einfach ein europäisches technisches Rahmenwerk geben und wenn man dann nicht mitmachen will, dann hat man eh ein Problem.
Ja und die äh das äh denke, das muss man auch nochmal klarstellen, dass werden die mit ihrer Lösung erfüllen können. Diese Blockchain sind einfach nur ein unnötiger Blinddarm an der ganzen Angelegenheit.
Jo, dann haben wir noch ein bisschen was Neues zu dem.
Ähm wir haben ja äh schon hier vor einiger Zeit darüber gesprochen, dass das BKA gemeinsam mit mehreren anderen ähm,
internationalen Behörden, Behörden, die ähm diese Emoje-Infrastruktur übernommen hat und jetzt eben beabsichtigt.
Einerseits den die Opfer, die jetzt quasi sich meinen, die infizierten Rechner, die meinen, sich mit dem Kontrollsystem zu verbinden, erstmal bei sich hinzuleiten und jetzt eine
ähm also eine Deinstallation von diesen Geräten vornehmen wollen, ja? Und.
Sie haben äh genau, die Behörden sind äh Ukraine, Niederlande, Großbritannien und die USA, mit denen sie da zusammen gearbeitet haben und sie haben jetzt ein Update durchgeführt.
Auf diesen Geräten, die da infiziert sind, diese Updatedatei hat Netzpolitik org auch bereitgestellt.
Durch dieses Update kommunizieren die dann eben mit Rechnern bei der Deutschen Telekom, melden ihre IP-Adresse den Rechnern und laufende Programme.
Das soll so laufen bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten April.
Dann soll diese staatliche Version sich deinstallieren und äh die Registry Einträge bei Windows, die also dazu führen, dass sie immer wieder aufgerufen wird, löschen. Damit wären dann die Rechner bereinigt.
Das haben sie sich diese veränderte Version haben sie sich von bauen lassen, ich verstehe,
bisher immer noch nicht, warum sie nicht einfach sowieso die Löschung durchgeführt haben und jetzt nochmal bis April warten und dann noch eine eigene Variante haben. Und ich kann natürlich verstehen, spätestens, wenn du jetzt sagst, alles klar
also
in dem Moment hat der Staat, den es eine Software offen Rechner installiert, die ihre IP-Adresse ihren Rechnernamen und die laufenden Programme irgendwo bei Server in die Deutsche Telekom meldet. Also das ist schon ein bisschen,
Komisch, ne?
Und da kann ich schon verstehen, dass das äh äh also das muss mir mal jemand erklären, warum das denn jetzt notwendig wäre.
Ähm von wie vielen Systemen da die Rede ist ähm.
Weg. Das BKA hat ihre Variante irgendwie auf zehntausenden äh System benannt, äh installiert. Die reden von dreiundfünfzigtausend betroffenen Systemen.
Dann.
Ist aber die Frage, ob das jetzt Deutschland äh oder weltweit ist? Also sie sagen, sie sagen nicht in welcher in welchen Ländern sich wie viele Rechner befinden.
Ja, das BSI.
Meldet aber quasi die vom BKA ermittelten IP-Adressen der betroffenen Rechner an die zuständigen Provider. Und die,
Deutsche Telekom sagt, die Zahl betroffener Kunden hatte schon vor dem die einhunderttausender Marke deutlich überschritten.
Ist jetzt irgendwie, also man fragt sich, was die da machen, wenn die Deutsche Telekom das schon vorher wusste, dann fragt man sich, warum die nicht ihren Kunden Bescheid gegeben haben, ne? Also das ist irgendwie alles. Ähm.
Ein bisschen sehr komisch. Also hier, man sieht, dass es hier keinen klaren äh
Prozess gibt, ne? Oder kein, kein definierten Prozess, denn es gibt ja auch einfach keine Rechtsgrundlage dafür, ne? Dass die eine Software auf deinen Rechner installieren, die durch für äh ausführen und damit eben nun mal von staatlicher Stelle auf,
dein Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von IT-Systemen eingreifen.
Insofern ist das äh sehr, sehr komisch. Also sie haben tatsächlich einfach keine Rechtsgrundlage dieses Grundrechts zu.
In dieses Grundrecht einzugreifen. Auch wenn das potenziell in deinem Interesse gibt,
Es gibt eben keine ähm rechtliche Grundlage für das, was sie da tun. Und,
interessant ist auch, sie fragen dich ja nicht, ob sie das tun sollen. Ja, also du wirst nicht irgendwie informiert darüber, dass das passieren wird und äh du kannst nicht sagen, nee, bitte, meine VM hier, ich will die Infektion gerne behalten.
Es ist also etwas komisch. Ich glaube, ähm man könnte.
Wahrscheinlich diese Schadsoftware Beispiel von Netzblutic Orks sich mal runterladen, dass in einer VM installieren und dann mal schauen, was diese VM so macht. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein ganz interessanter äh,
Ganz interessant für Forscherinnen und ja, die rechtliche Grundlage fehlt, vermutlich ist das, was sie da tun unterm Strich.
Sinnvoll und gut, aber das äh ändert eben nichts daran, dass es äh keine Rechtsgrundlage hat und dass es deswegen halt grundsätzlich falsch ist.
Mit anderen Worten, die werden natürlich äh relativ zügig sich die Rechtsgrundlage schaffen und ich hatte ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass das eben in der äh in dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null auch vorkommt, dieses Thema.
So, dann wissen wir inzwischen etwas mehr über die Check-In-Funktion, die die Corona-Warn-App bekommen soll. Hier noch einmal zur Erinnerung, es gibt das,
Infektionsschutzgesetz und auf Basis des Infektionsschutzgesetzes, die Corona-Verordnungen quasi der Länder, in denen.
Unterschiedliche Maßnahmen definiert werden. Und spezifisch ist in diesem Gefüge,
Anforderungen der Erfassung von Kontaktdaten von Besucherinnen, gastronomischer Einrichtungen oder in anderer Einrichtungen auch äh festgelegt,
und dieser, diesen rechtlichen Anforderungen will ja die Luca-App,
entsprechen. Gleichzeitig gab's jetzt aber eine sehr schöne ähm Diskussionsveranstaltung online.
An der äh Entwickler von Luca und Recover,
teilgenommen haben. Recover ist quasi eine Konkurrenz von Luca und ähm es war irgend so eine, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das stattgefunden hat, irgend so eine Zoom-Konferenz, die dann äh gestreamt wird, ne, mit ähm.
Dem Johannes Kasper äh der vom Landeslift ähm.
Landesamt für Datenschutz oder was? Also auf jeden Fall der Datenschützer von Hamburg und Karsten Neumann,
der der Datenschutz oder vom vom Datenschutz
Landesdaten Landesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit Mecklenburg-Vorpommern AD, also außer Dienst. Äh die haben da irgendwie drüber diskutiert und,
Interessant ist, dass äh in diesen Dingen der Satz viel niemand braucht eine personenbezogene Kontakterfassung, also selbst diejenigen, die diese Systeme bauen.
Wissen, dass sie das eigentlich nicht, dass man das eigentlich nicht braucht, sagt hier in dem Fall Jan Fuß, der Entwickler von Recover. Wir wollten keine Kontakt
Daten erfassen, aber wir mussten das, um der Gastronomie Hilfe anzubieten, äh wenn es, so weit es nicht mehr erforderlich ist.
Das ist eben die die Verordnung, die das vorschreibt, äh werden wir diese Daten sofort in die Tonne werfen.
Also Jubelcover sagt auch, eigentlich wär's sinnvoll äh zu machen. Äh es gibt mit schon eine Umsetzung dieses Konzeptes. Und das wäre,
der sinnvolle Weg. Ja.
Wird aber nicht gegangen.
Der wird interessanterweise nicht gegangen, obwohl ja und das ist ja wirklich die Schizophrie.
Obwohl jetzt das von vom Bundesministerium für Gesundheit beauftragte, äh Update der Corona-Warn-App ein,
zumindest für die Nutzerinnen anonymes System einbaut,
Das heißt, die bauen. Das BMG gibt gerade Geld aus für eine Lösung, die nach ihren eigenen Gesetzen und Verordnungen nicht den nicht entspricht. Ähm so, das ist sehr ähnlich. Crowd Notifyer.
Aber nicht hundert Prozent. Es funktioniert also so, der die Venue macht einen QR-Code,
In dem QR-Code ist der Name eine ID und eine Signatur untergebracht. Es ist relativ unklar, warum da eine Signatur dran ist, weil ja sowieso jede Person und jede Wennige sich eigentlich so ein, so einen QR-Code bauen kann.
Aber es gibt eine Signatur. Ähm die die Venues werden.
Ermutigt diesen QR-Code regelmäßig zu ändern.
Es ist natürlich so, dass ihr es wahrscheinlich nicht machen werden, ne. Die werden denen im Zweifelsfall einmal ausdrucken äh auf die Tische kleben oder an die Tür oder was auch immer, ne? Und werden den jetzt nicht ähm,
regelmäßig ändern. Sollten sie aber eigentlich. So, jetzt kommen die Besucherinnen und scannen einen QR-Code.
Der also die ID dieser Location speichert. So und jetzt.
Dezentral, ne? Nur auf ihrem Rechner. Ähm der Grundgedanke ist, die Gesundheitsämter sind langsam.
Und ähm ineffizient also machen wir.
Dieser der Grundgedanke ist natürlich diskussionswürdig. Wir melden einfach alle, die auch in dieser Location waren.
Und zwar wenn du eben den zum Hochladen bekommen hast.
Mit dem du jetzt auch deine Corona-Warnapp Bluetooth-Keys hochlädst, dann lädst du auch alle Identifiere hoch von Locations und die jeweilige Zeit.
Ähm der Nachteil ist, dass das natürlich jetzt keine, also nachdem wie es jetzt im Moment aussieht,
keine Unterscheidung macht,
dass du zum Beispiel deine Locations nochmal aussuchst oder wen du genau alarmierst. Das heißt, eigentlich wäre es in diesem Fall sinnvoller, irgendeine Form von Abstufungen da reinzubringen, dass du,
vielleicht potenziell sagst OK dieser Ort war jetzt irgendwie 'n Theater, wenn ich hier eine Warnung bekomme dann,
reicht es mir, wenn die gelb ist, weil ich weiß ja, wer in meiner Nähe saß und mit den Leuten habe ich vielleicht über die Corona-Warn-App etwas, weil wenn die Location zu groß wird,
dann hast du halt dann alarmierst du zu viele Leute, ne? Ähm.
Das Schöne an dem System ist, es werden wieder quasi nur diese IDs veröffentlicht und die die checken lokal.
Jetzt hast du das äh.
Folgende Probleme. Das Telefon speichert eben trotzdem diese Locations. Ne, die sind also auf deinem äh Telefon drauf.
Immerhin glücklicherweise aber nur dort. Jetzt ähm aber wenn die Locations ihre äh Tokens nicht regelmäßig ändern.
Ist die Folge, dass du eigentlich keine Anonymität für die Locations mehr hast. Denn du kannst jetzt einfach, na, als interessierte Bürgerin durch deinen Kiez gehen, scannt die ganzen QR-Codes von den Locations.
Lies die einfach aus mit einem QR-Code-Lesegerät und wenn dann die Meldungen sind, dann wären die quasi, sind die öffentlich, ne? Wenn die Location sich keine, also weil die Location keine Anonymität hat.
Der nächste, das nächste Problem ist bei der Geschwindigkeit, dass es theoretisch auch mit den Personen Kies korrelieren könntest, also je je schneller die Meldung ist, desto weniger,
Locations werden pro Zeiteinheit gemeldet und desto weniger Personenschlüssel werden pro Zeiteinheit gemeldet. Ähm.
Also kriegst du granulareres Wissen, weil du weißt, okay, wenn hier die Personen kurz kommen.
Und gleichzeitig die Location Codes, dann weißt du zumindest, dass diese Personenkreuz wahrscheinlich an diesen Locations waren.
Was ein potentielles Risiko für die Location äh für die Personencodes auch ist, aber ähm es wird ja tatsächlich unter die Personencodes werden ja auch Fake Codes gemischt.
Ja? Das also du kriegst äh wenn du jedes Mal wenn du dir ähm Alarmierung runter,
sind Fake Codes dabei, um das weiter aufzumischen.
Ähm und tja, die Sache, mit dem man alarmiert alle.
Ohne Kontextualisierung wird das halt potenziell einfach zu führen, ne? Ich hatte ja schon gesagt, dass sehr,
häufig in der, also es im Moment,
Quasi Best practice bei den Gesundheitsämtern ist, nicht die Locations zu informieren. Weil sie sagen, okay, wir bewerten die Situation dort, wir unterscheiden in Primärkontakte und,
ähm ja, wahrscheinlich nicht besonders hohe Risikokontakte und wir konzentrieren uns auf die Primärkontakte.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn du dem nicht folgst. Und jetzt nicht irgendwie einen Prozess hast, der dir, der dich anleitet, nur bestimmte zu alarmieren, dann könnte es halt sein, dass du einfach viel zu viele alarmierst.
Und es ist grundsätzlich auch noch möglich, einfach mehr Locations zu senden. Wenn du dich aber mit den ähm.
Auseinandersetzt, also mit den Gesundheitsämtern und fragst, okay Leute, mal ganz ab von von allem.
Was wollt ihr eigentlich, ne? Was ist das, was ihr Epidemieologisch haben wollt? Was warum macht ihr das? Ihr braucht ja ihr wollt ja nicht Adressen haben. Ne, was ist die Grundlage eures Handelns? Und dann sagen die, naja, wir wollen Cluster.
Keine Listen,
Wir wollen also wissen, wo potentiell Clustersituationen waren, damit wir auf die gezielt zugreifen können. Und das wäre jetzt so wie sich das im Moment
darstellt, noch ist es ja nicht final, ne? Man kann nur bei Gitter blunkern, blunkern. Ähm,
sieht es nicht so aus, als würden sie diese Unterscheidung ermöglichen. Das wäre aber wahrscheinlich sinnvoll. Die in irgendeiner Form dort nochmal mit ähm einzubauen.
Ähm bist du mit der technischen Aufzählung jetzt schon fertig.
Ja, das wären so, also das wären jetzt so mein Kurzzusammenfassung von dem, was da so.
Also das war jetzt ganz schön viel. Also meine erste Frage wäre,
Hm, ist denn jetzt deine Erkenntnis nach hier vorgesehen so ein Check-in und so ein Checkout zu haben, also dass man sozusagen das für das rein und das Rausgehen in separaten QR-Code hat und dann auch die Leute entsprechend ermutigt
ähm den zu benutzen, weil diese Einschränkung der Zeit ist ja dann bei auf jeden Fall auch so ein Thema gewesen, davon habe ich jetzt hier nix gehört,
dass das nur übersehen oder vielleicht ist es auch nicht dabei, das weiß ich nicht.
Mal kurz, also ich habe das, ich es gibt ja einen Draft Summary von von dem Feature.
Jetzt gucken wir mal ganz kurz, äh wie das genau geregelt ist. Also wenn wir uns dieses die QR-Code-Struktur anschauen, dann ist quasi in dem.
QR-Code steht einfach zum Beispiel eine drin.
Was vielleicht gar nicht so dumm ist. Ja, zu sagen, also eine Bäckerei wird halt sagen, okay, die die voll Check-in-Lenk ist halt hier zum Beispiel in dem bei acht Minuten.
Länger steht hier keiner rum.
Genau. Und jetzt würde ich vermuten, dass du.
Mal gucken. Also wenn sie den Begriff Länges haben, dass wir die auch nochmal manuell anpassen kannst. Das steht hier aber nicht. Also ich lese nur, dass sie eine Diefolgdauer einfach schon mal vorgeben.
Aber es gibt ja so Location-Tipps, die sie hier vorgeben und daraus leiten sie das unter Umständen so einen so einen bestimmten
ab, den man dann gegebenenfalls noch anpassen kann. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach so das, was
praktisch machbar ist, weil das diese Check-Out äh Dinger dann immer gescannt werden, ist das einer, ne. Time die dann irgendwie aus, also es gibt ja hier so einen Start und auch drin, also
Man könnte die Leute ja auch zwingen, sozusagen regelmäßig neue QR-Codes zu machen.
Ja, dass das also die die Locations meinst du, ne?
Ja, das meine ich.
Ja, das wäre, das könnte man vielleicht auch machen. Es ist natürlich.
Also die Frage ist, willst du Privacy für Locations haben oder nicht? Ist halt
schwierig. Ich denke, es wäre sinnvoller, klar, aber natürlich mindestens denen, die da waren, sagst du's eh, ne? Also du kriegst es nicht hin, selbst wenn die Location.
Anonym wäre.
Ähm müssen ja auch die Leute, die müssen ja korrekt einchecken, ne. Also wäre ja auch zum Beispiel ein Angriff, dass du falsche QR-Codes an die Orte klebst,
Ja, also sagen wir mal, du machst dir jetzt den Aufwand und klebst überall den gleichen QR-Code hin.
Um dann quasi zu potenzieren, wenn einer meldet, dass er nicht nicht nur eine Kneipe, sondern die ganze Straße lahmlegt oder so. Aber das sind alles eigentlich keine gangbaren Angriffe. Location Privacy kannst du ganz einfach,
dadurch herstellen, dass du den QR-Code regelmäßig änderst und die einfache Möglichkeit wäre, ne? Du, du als,
was weiß ich, die Geschäftsführerin oder wer auch immer stellt morgens den neuen Code des Tages ein und schickt den in die WhatsApp-Gruppe der Belegschaft, ne? Und die können schön am Tisch bei dir einfach kurz hingehen und sagen, hier zack
scannen wir eben ab, Thema durch, ne. Also sobald du das nicht mehr mit Ausdrucken machst, hast du das, hast du das Problem auch äh auch wieder gelöst.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist so der Vorschlag, der jetzt hier umgesetzt wird, äh folgt im Prinzip denselben Ideen, wie der Crowd Notifyer scheint nicht so eine hundertprozentige Umsetzung
des Konzepts zu sein, aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt in einem dramatisch schlechteren Maße.
Es ist sehr nah dran angelegt. Du kannst mit äh du kannst natürlich mit mit oder du kannst einfach auch,
schönere Dinge machen, indem du halt die Location-ID nochmal weiter verkalkulierst mit mit dem Datum oder sonstigen, ne, um sie für Leute, die nicht da waren,
schwer lesbar zu machen. Und das ist das, was ähm was Crowd-Notifyer macht,
Ja, dass sie also sagen, okay, wir, was hier gescannt wird, ist ein gemeinsames Geheimnis von allen, die es kennen. Ja, und nur mit diesem Geheimnis kannst du quasi wieder entschlüsseln, dass auch diese Location gemeint ist.
Aber trotzdem können eben alle, die da waren, können's dann eben trotzdem erkennen, ne. Ähm.
In dem Git-Up sagen sie sie, sie priorisieren Geschwindigkeit über Genauigkeit.
Ja, sie sagen, wir wir waren lieber einfach schnell alle und da wird sich eben zeigen, ich glaube, dass das zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten oder zu unterschiedlicher Höhe der Inzidenz die richtige oder die falsche Entscheidung sein kann,
Und wenn die Inzidenz so hoch ist, wie sie jetzt in Deutschland ist ähm und du würdest jetzt äh eine Öffnungen haben,
dann wäre das eben sehr ungünstig, wenn du immer direkt das gesamte, die gesamte
für diesen Zeitraum. Immerhin muss er sagen, für den Zeitraum ähm alarmierst, ne? Das könnten eben potenziell viele zehn äh Nutzer zu viel sein, die du da alarmierst
grundsätzlich bei einer niedrigen Inzidenz hingegen kann das sehr sinnvoll sein.
Ja, weil das eben dann sagt, alles klar. Zack. Und jetzt alle mal Vorsicht. Und hier du hast die Warnung. Begib dich in begib dich bitte in fünf fünf Minuten in Ruhe oder sonst was. Ne, das würde dann klappen.
Ja und ich meine hochinzidenzzeiten brauchen sowieso andere Maßnahmen. Ich meine, die ergreifen wir derzeit nicht. Das ist eine andere Diskussion. Äh es geht äh immer da drum, dass man äh grundsätzlich erstmal eine kontrollierbare,
kontrollierbare Situation anstrebt und darin dann Maßnahmen ergreift, um einen ausbrechen und damit eine Verschlimmerung der Situation wieder zu verhindern. Derzeit leben wir halt so so eine permanenten Paniksituation und haben auch
keine Bereitschaft mehr äh bei den Leuten irgendwie noch äh sinnvolle Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
Was man ja auch daran sieht, dass jetzt irgendwie mit Berlin, glaube ich, auch schon das zweite Bundesland der Meinung ist, jetzt müssten wir ja mal die Luca-App kaufen. Ja und nochmal sinnlos, Geld rausschmeißen
an sich schon mal äh bekloppt ist, aber dazu eben auch noch beiträgt, dass man dann eben den dann eine Lösung
empfiehlt, die dann eben nicht die Lösung der Corona-Warnapp ist und damit die Corona-Warnapp diskreditiert und damit sich damit auch nochmal,
ein Stock in die Speichen reinsteckt. Das ist einfach die das Maß an Dummheit ist einfach voll irgendwie und ich finde es geht einfach langsam mal aufhören.
Auch so schlimm ey. Leute, echt. Michael Müller, ja, ich meine, setzt sich da wirklich vor die Kameras und meint so, ja, also ähm,
Ich habe mich da jetzt nicht mit den Details und und der Technik äh beschäftigt. Ich habe die einfach mal bestellt. So und das war so im Wesentlichen seine Aussage,
Ja, ja, okay, du hast dich nicht damit in Details beschäftigt und äh machst halt einfach mal irgendwas. Okay, weekend sie tat. Clialy.
Äh man möchte wirklich nur noch so rumlaufen wie so ein Steinzeitmensch.
Na ja, okay, dann machen wir mal weiter,
ein klassisches, ein klassisches Netzpolitikthema, ja? Netzsperren, DNS sperren sind zurück,
muss man, also das kann man ja mal wieder neu erklären im Logbuch, das hatten wir einige Zeit nicht.
Wenn ihr im Internet seid mit eurem Browser und ihr möchtet einen Server besuchen. Zum Beispiel.
Logbuch Minus Netzpolitik DE. Dann kontaktiert ihr diesen Server,
eigentlich über seine IP-Adresse, ja?
Und zwar ist die IP-Adresse, ich gucke mir das mal gerade kurz an von Logbuch Minus Netzpolitik DE ist IT V vier,
Eins drei acht Punkt zwei null eins Punkt acht null Punkt sechs acht. Ja? Es gibt auch noch eine,
Adresse, aber die ist zu lang, um sie jetzt vorzulesen. Ähm obwohl, kann man auch mal machen, das ist die zwei A null eins Doppelpunkt vier, F acht, Doppelpunkt eins, sieben zwei Doppelpunkt, eins zehn null drei, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt eins
Doppelpunkt sechs.
Wisst ihr Bescheid jetzt.
Wisst ihr Bescheid. So. Könnt ihr auch. Geht also auch viel einfacher auf unsere Seite zu kommen. Ähm und.
Dieses System, was dort Anwendung findet, ist das äh DNS-System und da werden große, große Server vorgehalten, die,
Datenbanken haben von welche Domain zeigt auf welche IP. Und ein sehr unkluger.
Oder sehr, sehr wenig erfolgsversprechender.
Weg, den Zugriff auf eine Seite zu verhindern, ist, dass man auf den Namen Servern einfach nicht mehr die korrekte Antwort gibt,
ja? Weil es gibt von diesen natürlich auch eine Antwort darauf, dass es eine Domain nicht gibt,
Dann kommt einfach zurück. Ja, diese Domain gibt's nicht und die Konsequenz ist eben entweder du musst sie dir jetzt kaufen, weil sie voll geil ist oder du guckst nochmal, ob du einfach ein Taipo gemacht hast, ne? Und.
Die Idee war, ist seit vielen Jahren.
Dass man hier quasi eingreift, von Seiten der Provider, die DNS-Server betreiben,
und dann eingreift. Das tun die auch teilweise, je nachdem bei welchem Provider ihr seid, in unterschiedlichem Ausmaß, beispielsweise, wenn ihr euch irgendwie vertippt,
und es gibt keinen DNS-Eintrag, dass sie euch zu irgendeiner obskuren Suchseite umleiten,
und sagen, ey, du hast gesucht. Willst du nicht mehr hier bei der T-Online Suche gucken oder so, ne? Also da gibt es schon.
Verletzungen der Integrität äh dieses Systems. Und jetzt ähm also,
Das wurde damals sehr lange diskutiert unter dieser Idee der Stoppschilder. Ja, da hat also es war auch Ursula, von der Leyen, die damals so vorgestellt hat. Hier, pass auf, weil ist ja offenbar,
ganz viele Webseiten mit dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch gibt, die wir nicht aus dem Internet rauskriegen, wollen wir jetzt auf den DNS-Servern quasi dann umleiten auf eine zentrale Stelle, wo dann ein Stop-Schild ist.
Eine Idee, die ähm ja, jetzt nicht, also nicht so, nicht so überzeugend.
Lass es, lass es mich so sagen, sie hat sich mit den technischen Details nicht so auseinandergesetzt, sie hat's einfach mal bestellt.
Einfach mal bestellt und dann, also es war eine eine ähm ja, eines der Themen, das muss so zweitausendneun ungefähr.
Zensursular.
Debatte.
Warte mal.
Schön finde ich, dass man Ursula von der Leyen in der Wikipedia auch findet, wenn man nach Zonsursula sucht. Ähm das war zweitausendneun, ja, ja, mhm, hm, hm.
Diese Zeit,
großes Thema, weil, ne, wie immer, es ging los mit Urheberrecht und dann weißt du, ne, wenn so etwas jetzt auf gesetzlicher Ebene eingeführt wird, dann weißt du, das dauert nicht lange, bis sich das ähm bis sich das ausweitet und andere sagen, die Internetseiten wollen wir übrigens auch nicht haben
Jetzt kommt aber der der äh der der warum diese Idee so dumm ist, ist du du kannst dir natürlich einfach einen anderen DNS-Server eintragen, der diese Zensur nicht vornimmt und dann kriegst du natürlich auch noch die Antwort,
also man wird es dir nicht verhindern können, dass du ähm einen entsprechenden,
Zensur freien DNS-Server findest oder selber betreibst oder dir von mir aus auch einfach in deinen reinschreibst, dass diese spezifische Seite unter folgender IP ist, was dazu führt, dass dein Computer einfach kein
DNS-Request mehr absendet, ja? Also du kannst in,
System in ETC Horse, bei Windows gibt's die auch, liegt irgendwo anders. Da schreibst du im Prinzip eine IP-Adresse unter Domain rein ähm und dann.
Verzichtest, das ist dann quasi deine lokale DNS Tabelle. Also diese Sperrmethode ist sehr äh.
Löchrig. Bedeutet, sie betrifft natürlich, und das war natürlich auch vor allem die Diskussion bei dieser Zensur so einer Debatte. Sie trifft dann halt nicht diejenigen, die wirklich solche Seiten besuchen, sofern es denn überhaupt,
Webseiten gäbe in diesem Internet, die dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch ganz einfach zugänglich machen und äh,
irgendwie nicht von den,
zuständigen Behörden sofort unterbunden werden. Ja, das war übrigens in der Zensursolla-Debatte eben auch der Nachweis, der nicht geführt wurde, da wurde dann behauptet, in bestimmten Ländern wäre,
dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch legal und dann meldeten sich die Länder so und sagten so, hör mal,
Was habt denn ihr da? Wat erzählt ihr denn da für einen Scheiß, ne? Äh wir sind ein strengen muslimisches Land, so bei uns ist gar nichts mit Sex erlaubt so, ne? Und es waren also ähm.
Und da gab dann kam dann eben auch diese entsprechende Forderung, die sehr stark äh vertreten wurde von der gesamten,
Bürgerrechts- und Netzcommunity löschen statt sperren. Also wenn jemand so etwas,
veröffentlicht, dann deckt da, macht, legt da keinen Deckmantel drüber, sondern führt die der Strafverfolgung zu. Und das funktioniert auch jedes Jahr sehr gut, ja, dass es eben diese Meldestellen gibt für,
Server oder sonst was, die so etwas bereithalten und die werden dann eben äh beschlagnahmt und die Betreiberinnen verfolgt.
So gehört sich das eben. So, da,
Solche Sachen kommen immer mit Terror und Urheberrecht, ja? Das sind so die die Themen, die die Leute interessieren,
und ähm oder Entschuldigung, mit Terror und äh dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch und dann stehen in der zweiten Reihe dann natürlich die Urheberrechtslobby. Und die haben jetzt sehr simpel.
Weil sie sie, weil es dafür eben keine Rechtsgrundlage gibt und sonst was, eine Clearingstelle Urheberrecht im Internet gegründet.
Und zwar die Verbände der Urheberrechtsindustrie zusammen mit,
Internet Providern Eins und Eins, Mobilcom Deli, Debitel, Telefonica, Telekom und Vodafone. Ja, damit hättest du alle Mobilfunknetze.
In Deutschland alle drei und ähm die Kabelnetze, die sind ja, glaube ich, bei Vodafone in in oder Vodafone hat die gerade gekauft, ne?
Mhm. Ja, weitgehend zumindest.
DSL Netz ist größtenteils Telekom, der größte Reseller von DSL, Zugängen der Deutschen Telekom ist, glaube ich, ähm Eins und Eins.
Und ähm damit hast du dann schon wirklich sag mal, den größeren Teil der,
große Mehrheit der deutschen Internetzugänge abgedeckt, ja? Kartellamt und Bundesnetzagentur haben gesagt, ja ist in Ordnung, finden wir gut,
und in naher Zukunft möchten sie ein erstes Streamingportal sperren.
Sie konzentrieren sich laut eigenen Angaben eben auf Streaming-Seiten, die ihre Filme, Serien oder auch Musik kostenfrei illegal verfügbar machen. Und ähm,
wir haben über solche Seiten auch schon vor einigen Jahren mal gesprochen, da ist es meistens so.
Dass die tatsächlich nach so einer Art Hütchenspiel funktionieren. Die sagen halt, wir sind ein Forum, da kannst du.
Eintragen und.
Wir stellen das dann zur Verfügung und das ist jetzt User Generation, für den wir ja erst verantwortlich sind, wenn es uns jemand meldet. Und wenn es uns jemand meldet, okay.
Dann löschen wir diesen Eintrag. Das eigentliche Hosting findet aber woanders statt. Und dadurch versuchen die eben quasi.
Ja, Gesetzeslücken in dem Notes in TakeDown zu finden. Ähm wir haben auch vor einigen Jahren darüber berichtet, dass da mit Kino TO ähm tatsächlich eine wirklich eine, ja,
professionell industrialisierte Bande hinter steckte, die quasi.
Genau nicht nur ein Forum betrieben hat, sondern sehr gezielt Content aquiriert hat, Menschen dafür bezahlt hat und das mit diesem, mit dieser illegalen Seite sich eben tatsächlich bereichert haben. Ähm,
sodass diesen Streaming-Seiten würde ich sagen, insgesamt immer schon so ein bisschen.
Ja, da bist du eigentlich nicht in guten Händen, ne? Die wollen, die machen damit Geld, die schalten die Seiten mit Werbung voll, die machen da halt tatsächlich einen geschäftsmäßigen.
Profitorientierten äh Urheberrechtsverletzungsbetrieb und das sind jetzt nicht deine Freunde, ne? Ähm,
anders sieht's vielleicht aus, wenn du so im Bereich des Tourenting unterwegs bist, aber da hast du ja immer das große Risiko, wenn du da nicht einen ordentlichen VPN-Router dazwischen hast,
dass ähm,
eben früher oder später Post kriegst von Waldof Frommer, die wiederum eine Industrie daraus gebaut haben, die Abmahnungen zu verschicken, weil du dann eben bereitstellst
Bei den Streamingseiten ist es allerdings so, dass du ja nur konsumierst und dich als Nutzerin der Streaming-Seite nicht strafbar machst.
Also äh so so mal zur Kurzeinführung, ja und das möchten sie also jetzt hier,
machen, also sie wollen eine Clearingstelle haben, die.
Dann eben gemeinsam entscheidet, jetzt sperren wir den diesen DNS-Eintrag und äh unser.
Von der von der vom Bundeskartellamt genehmigtes Kartell der Netzbetreiber schließt dann jetzt eben äh verständigt sich darauf, diese DNS-Sperre,
ähm.
Umzusetzen. Das ist relativ krass, weil das komplett außergerichtlich ist. Ne, also du hast jetzt hier als Betroffene Seite.
Ähm Schwierigkeiten, dich dem entgegenzusetzen, dich dagegen zu wehren.
Und natürlich ist es auch schwierig, wenn die sich jetzt entscheiden, ach so, das hat mit dem Urheberrecht schon mal super funktioniert. Jetzt wollen wir mal noch,
was weiß ich, dieses und jenes aus dem Internet raus haben und dann bist du relativ zügig,
ähm eben in dem Bereich, wo wo du schwere Einschränkungen der Kommunikationsfreiheit hast, ne? Würde Russland
oder China ein solches Gesetz diskutieren, dann wäre hier der Aufschrei groß, weil es eben, ne, eine Privatisierung äh,
ohne Rechtsweg ist,
und du nicht weißt, also bisher ist nur die Rede von einem Gremium, die haben ja aber noch nicht genau gesagt, wie das Gremium aussieht. Sie haben's auf jeden Fall unter sich ausgemacht und die Zivilgesellschaft sitzt da nicht mit dran. Ähm.
Und die Bundesnetzagentur sagt sogar Jörg Geil, das wird ja jetzt äh viel effizienter, was äh eine sehr, sehr.
Beunruhigende Entwicklung ist. Dagegen sollte man sich äh wehren, also genau,
die Bundesletzagent für sagt, das neue Verfahren hilft, langwierige und kostspielige Gerichtsverfahren zu vermeiden
die Rechteinhaber bislang angewiesen sind. Die Bundesnetzagentur leistet ihren Beitrag, um die Vorgaben zu Netzneutralität zu sichern. Da frage ich mich jetzt, wie der die Vorgaben der Netzneutralität gesichert werden, wenn ein private,
Gruppe entscheidet das eine Seite nicht mehr online sein wird oder ein DNS-Eintrag gelöscht wird,
ist also irgendwie komisch. Ja, also es kommt einem sehr komisch vor, was da die.
Bundesnetzagentur macht. Es gibt keine gerichtliche Prüfung und die Netzagentur ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die richtige Stelle für Grundrechtsabwägungen.
Nee, klingt so ein bisschen wie ein Fall fürs fürs Verfassungsgericht unterm Strich.
Also das ist äh schwierig, ne? Kollateralschäden kannst du jetzt schon sehen, was da alles passieren wird und ähm.
Das klingt nach einer relativ schwierigen Idee, ja? Also klassische ähm.
Privatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung, wo du entsprechend dann auch keinen, keinen sauberen Weg hast, dich dagegen zu wehren. Das klingt problematisch. Äh Lösungsvorschlag,
ähm ist, sich vielleicht schon mal damit vertraut zu machen, wie man den DNS-Server in seinen äh Einstellungen ändert, ja?
Ähm kann man am Laptop dauerhaft einstellen, unter Netzwerkeinstellungen sagst du halt, okay, ich möchte nicht,
oder nicht nur den DNS-Server verwenden, den mein Provider mir gibt. In der Regel findest du bei Alternativen DNS-Servern äh auch höhere Performance, ja?
Nicht unbedingt.
Na ja, also vielleicht sind die Server als solche schneller, aber äh ist natürlich auch ein Teil des Problems, dass dir,
IP-Adressen, die dir an der einen Stelle genannt werden, nicht unbedingt diesen, die an der anderen Stelle genannt werden. Ja, da ein Beispiel von vorhin hier Logbuch Netzpolitik, da könnt ihr überall auf dem ganzen Planeten nachfragen. Ihr werdet immer dieselbe Nummer bekommen. Aber wenn's halt dadrum geht, mit.
Denn jetzt mein Netflix-Filmchen äh her, dann wird natürlich idealerweise ein ähm eine Adresse ausgespuckt, die,
nah an dir dran ist, damit die Daten nicht so weit gehen müssen. Und wenn du jetzt so einen öffentlichen Fluchtserver wie äh was weiß ich hier, google DNS oder so, acht acht acht benutzt
dann ähm sind diese Optimierungen unter Umständen nicht äh von der selben Güte und das
führt dann schon mal zu Problemen, aber wenn die Frage ist, kann ich auf etwas zugreifen oder nicht, dann hilft's natürlich auf jeden Fall.
Okay, ja, das also was Tim grade meint, ist zum insbesondere die Netflix-Dinger stehen auch gerne mal einfach direkt beim Provider im Schrank,
ja? Und dann ist das natürlich potentiell äh mit Verlangsamung hm einhergehend, wenn du jetzt äh dann stattdessen versuchst, sie das irgendwie aus den USA zu holen. Ähm.
Das mag äh sein. Also insgesamt das Problem ist, dass es das überhaupt gibt und das ist sehr erstaunlich, dass die BNEtz A sich da irgendwie so,
so hinstellt und sagt, alles klar, machen wir und das ist irgendwie alles nicht so alles nicht, keine schöne Entwicklung, ne? Da haben wir
viele Jahre begründet gegen gekämpft und die Sorge ist halt dann eben wie sich das wie sich das zügig ausweiten wird, weil wenn das erstmal da ist, dann wird nämlich Folgendes passieren, dass andere Leute.
Versuchen, die Sperrung unterschiedlicher Seiten quasi zu erklagen. Ja, und zu sagen, ihr habt ja,
Infrastruktur. Ihr könnt das, es gibt etwas im Internet, das finde ich nicht gut und die Deutsche Telekom ist jetzt Schuld daran,
Ja und das ist, ne, es wird am Ende diejenigen nicht treffen
die es treffen soll, weil wenn du jetzt so eine Streamingseite betreibst, dann sagst du jetzt den Leuten schon mal übrigens, ne, hier ist ein DNS,
äh Server, den ihr eintragen könnt, der uns immer auflöst. Das ist nämlich unser eigener DNS-Server oder ne, hier ist das, was ihr in euer Haus falsch schreiben solltet mit unserer fixen IP. Wobei ich vermute, dass die,
bei denen nicht lange helfen wird, weil die ja auch regelmäßig umziehen mit ihren äh Dingern.
Und ja, du triffst dann halt am Ende wieder nur die Falschen. Das ist nicht, nicht gut, hat sie da gemacht haben.
Nee, überhaupt nicht gut.
Währenddessen bietet YouTube jetzt quasi ähm Upload-Filter an, also Feature.
Ähm und zwar ist das so ähm.
Wenn du bei YouTube ein Video hochlädst und beispielsweise darin ein Inhalt ist oder eine Musik,
die per Content ID,
detektiert und dann potentiell automatisch abgeschaltet oder gelöscht wird, ne? Gibt ja unterschiedliche Maßnahmen von YouTube, teilweise, wenn da wenn da Musik drin ist, wo sie glauben, dass du die nicht rechtmäßig verwendest, dann machen die bei dem Video einfach den Ton aus, ne. Ähm
wenn du aber komplette Inhalte von jemand anderem verwendest, dann löschen sie potenzielle auch mal das ganze Video oder sie ähm.
Sagen dir, OK, du kannst es weiter verwenden, aber du darfst das Video nicht mehr monetarisieren, gibt also unterschiedliche,
Maßnahmen, die die ergreifen oder nicht. Und die kommen aber üblicherweise nach deinem Upload, also in der Regel so vierundzwanzig Stunden später
ist so mein Gefühl. Könne auch achtundvierzig sein. Auf jeden Fall dauert das seine Zeit. Und das hat eben meistens auch das Problem, dass das so die Zeit ist, in der das Video dann viral,
gerade und dann zack ist es weg, ne? Und nimmt dir quasi den,
als als Produzentin des Videos oder als Veröffentlicherin, ebenso den Peak der Aufmerksamkeit weg. Haben wir ja auch schon oft genug drüber besprochen. Jetzt bauen sie das als Checks ein.
Ines uploade und sagen, pass auf, du kannst, wenn du das Video hochlädst, wenn das fertig hochgeladen ist, kannst du hier auf Checks drücken, dann dauert's ein paar Minuten,
und dann sagen wir dir, was wir da für Probleme haben. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt, also sie verkaufen's dir als Feature, dass du den,
dass du den Scheck vor vorher machen kannst und dadurch nicht diese böse Überraschung hast, wenn der halt ein paar Stunden später zuschlägt. Du kannst Widerspruch einlegen, allerdings kann das dann etwas dauern.
Bist du äh bis es geklärt wird. Du kannst auch einfach sofort veröffentlichen und auf die Entscheidung warten. Ja? Ähm.
Und.
Ja, sagen dann, wenn's also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel in der Situation bist, dass die sagen, naja, das gehörte ihr eigentlich jemand anderem, dann behalten sie erstmal deine die Werbeeinnahmen ein.
Also damit sie die auf jeden Fall schon mal trotzdem machen und wenn sie's dann geprüft haben, deinen Widerspruch, geht, geht es potenziell eben an dich, ansonsten an die äh Rechte Inhaber.
Es ist so ein bisschen äh.
Es ja schwierig. Ich weiß nicht genau, was ich davon halten soll. Ich meine, für die für die Youtuber ist es wahrscheinlich ein gutes Feature.
Weil es ihnen potentiell eben Probleme vorher meldet, was natürlich nichts daran erinnert, dass YouTube eben sich trotzdem nachher äh anders entscheiden kann, ne.
Also ich glaube.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das jetzt positiv oder negativ ist. Wahrscheinlich ist es, also wenn man sich überlegt, dass die Alternative ist, dass sie die einfach auf einmal dein Video abschießen ähm ist das jetzt natürlich die bessere Lösung?
Aber es sind halt Upload-Filter.
Ja, mal gut, aber ich meine, die haben uns halt jetzt eingetreten.
Ja, die haben sie ja eh schon seit Jahren, ne. Ja, es na, immerhin hast du eine Widerspruchmöglichkeit.
Ich denke, das können besser äh Youtuber selber beurteilen, die schon mal aus so Sperrungen hatten. Äh und es wird sie,
wie gut das jetzt tatsächlich ist, wird sich eben zeigen mit wie oft Leute den den Schecksknopf drücken
Das Ding sagt, alles klar, kannst du machen. Und dann trotzdem nachher das Video runtergerissen wird, ne. Tja.
Also nehmen wir mal so zur Kenntnis als als Feature von YouTube, dass sie wenigstens dir ihre ganzen Speer äh Detektions Algorithmen vorher zur Prüfung geben.
Mitteilen, ja.
Ja, dann haben wir noch eine eher kurze Meldung change dot org wurde tatsächlich.
Jetzt dauerhaft die Gemeinnützigkeit entzogen und ich finde, das ist.
Nicht gut, weil das ist eine Plattform, die ja eben der Gemeinschaft Petitionsmöglichkeiten und politische Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten bietet. Und das scheint mir nicht,
sinnvoll, dass man sagt, das ist nicht gemeinnützig, ganz im Gegenteil. Also, ich finde das sehr überraschend.
Ja, überraschend, äh äh es gibt eine ganze Welle von Gemeinnützigkeitsentzug. Das gab's ja
vorher schon mit äh Come act und so weiter und sicherlich kann man im Einzelnen auch äh immer darüber debattieren, inwiefern die Gemeinnützigkeit dann äh da tatsächlich verletzt wurde. Andererseits ist das eigentliche Problem, dass eben die Regelung für Gemeinnützigkeit einfach den der Zeit
entsprechend, ja? Die sind äh Regeln sind da sehr eng und grundsätzlich habe ich auch nix gegen äh klar formulierte Regeln, insbesondere, was so eine Steuerfreiheit betrifft.
Nur äh sind die einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß und äh das also die Maßstäbe, für was der Gemeinheit nützt,
haben sich halt einfach, müssen sich einfach ändern
weil sich die Zeit geändert hat, weil die Dienstleistungen äh sich ändern. Wir haben das hier auch, glaube ich, schon ein paar Mal besprochen im Kontext von Open Source äh Softwareentwicklung et cetera
Gemeinnützigkeit ähm für viele Organisationen sicherlich angemessen wäre, ja. Kann man Auflagen machen, kann man definieren, aber derzeit, wenn du versuchst, halt in irgendeiner Form
Gemeinnützigkeit ähm,
durchzuführen, indem du offene Software produzierst, die alle Leute benutzen können, ja? Und deren Anwendungen dann eben auch wirklich,
was bringt, äh dann kannst du das halt einfach nicht da reinschreiben so, sondern du musst verklausiliert irgendein Voodoo erfinden,
der so an diese äh äh altertümlichen äh Rechtsgebung sich ranschmiegt und
das ist halt äh kann's halt einfach nicht mehr sein. Ich kann das jetzt im Einzelnen mit mit Change Org nicht
beurteilen in ihrer Darstellung ist halt so, naja, wir haben ja hier gegen irgendwie die großen ähm Unternehmen äh protestiert, äh indem wir entsprechende Petitionen auf unserer Plattform hatten.
Ja, aber das ist der, das ist das, was ihnen halt quasi als Begründung,
geben, weil sie sagen, also Petitionsplattform wie Change dot org sind nur dann gemeinnützig, wenn sie ausschließlich Petitionen an staatliche Stellen zulassen, nicht aber an nichtstaatliche Stellen. Und also tatsächlich, dass sie eine Petition,
gegen oder an, was weiß ich, Nestlé machen oder wen auch immer, das wird ihnen quasi zu Last gelegt.
Dass es schon sehr äh komisch, ne? Also die.
Die teilen die Rechtsauffassung auch nicht, aber äh ja.
Ist schon sehr erstaunlich. Gleichzeitig ist es so, mit der Gemeinnützigkeit, ne, das ist schon ein ein zweischneidiges Schwert, weil.
Wenn du die Regeln für Gemeinnützigkeit zu locker machst, dann macht sich jeder einfach seine eigene kleine Geldwäschestiftung, ne? Und das willst du natürlich auch nicht.
Eben das ist das.
Also man muss da irgendwie drauf schauen, man muss da Regeln verhaben, die Regeln sind komisch. Ich habe das ja auch hier schon mehrmals zitiert, ne. Ähm digitale Gesellschaft, der Verein hat damals bei seiner ersten Anmeldung nicht.
Die äh die Gemeinnützigkeit anerkannt bekommen, weil äh die die Vereinszwecke nicht die gesetzlich anerkannten,
gemeinnützigen Zwecke waren,
Also da stand halt drin äh die Förderung von Grund und Freiheitsrechten und in dem Bescheid der Ablehnungsstand halt drin, die Förderung von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten äh ist kein gemeinnütziger Zweck
und dann muss das halt gemeinnütziger Zweck googeln und da steht dann sowas wie äh ne,
das ist das Kommunikation zwischen den Völkern, Religion und sowas, ne? Brauchtümer und dann äh musst du es halt sagen, alles klar. Das ist unser, das ist unser.
Freiheit kümmert uns jetzt nicht mehr.
Freiheit und Grundrechte und Freiheit nicht.
Genau, wir setzen uns jetzt nicht mehr für Grundrechte ein und sind jetzt gemeinnützig.
Ich hoffe mal, dass äh also ich finde eigentlich schon, diese ähm es gab da noch eine andere Plattform. Change dot org und was gab's noch?
Die hatten das gleiche Problem. Irgendwas mit A, es gibt auch noch so eine andere Petitionsplattform. Wie heißt denn die? Sag mal Tim.
Na ja, egal. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall mehrere Dinger. Äh es gibt äh Attack hat ja auch ihre äh äh Gemeinnützigkeit äh aberkannt bekommen. Das ist gerade das rasiert da grade durch. Und ich halte das äh nicht für,
besonders ähm sinnvoll. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass hier noch nicht das letzte,
Wort gesprochen ist bei dieser Change dot org Geschichte erscheint eine Entscheidung des Finanzamtes zu sein,
und sie wehren sich dagegen mit einer Petition. Und was sie löschen müssten, um gemeinnützig zu bleiben, sind die Petition mit dem äh,
stoppt die Siemensbeteiligung am australischen Mega-Kohle-Projekt, unser Trinkwasser gehört uns, nicht Coca-Cola und Shell und Nigeria, Ökozide weltweit strafbar machen. Das scheint jetzt alles schon eher ähm,
gemeinnützige Interessen zu sein, die da vertreten werden. Das sind nur Beispiele, die sie da benennen. In Wirklichkeit haben, geht es natürlich um Tausende.
Okay,
Damit sind wir bei den Jobangeboten, die wir ja hier regelmäßig machen. Dieses Mal äh wirbt die Geschäftsstelle der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz.
Mit einem Job und sie möchten gerne ein haben zu sechzig Prozent.
Die geht es also darum auch den Tiere zu zu stellvertreten und in rechtlichen Belangen, in allen rechtlichen Belangen eben die digitale Gesellschaft Schweiz zu beraten und zu vertreten.
Wir bieten eine vielseitige und verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe, bei der zukunftsweisende rechtliche Themen im digitalen Bereich mitgestaltet und in den demokratischen, politischen Diskurs eingebracht werden können.
Sie hätten gerne ein abgeschlossenes Masterstudium in Brecht, Begeisterung für Netzpolitik und für die Arbeit in einer NGO mit ehrenamtlichen Mitgliedern sowie technisches Flair,
Technisches Flair hätten sie auch gerne. Link, wo ihr euch bewerben könnt, findet.
Technisches Flair.
Schauen uns. Ja, technisches Flair wünsche ich mir auch.
Ja. Ich frage mich, woran man das äh festmachen könnte. Technisches Flair.
Nicht unter fünf Blockchains.
Das ist äh eine interessante Formulierung. Haben sie auch technisches Flair? Hm.
Ist echt so ein Wort, über das man sich relativ wenig Gedanken macht, was ist denn eigentlich bedeutet, ne? Ist das auch schon mal aufgefallen? Ist jetzt.
Ich höre das zum ersten Mal. Ich kann mal gucken, ob die das in ihrer Stellenausschreibung äh gucken.
Qualifikation. Dritte, drittwichtigste Qualifikation.
Ja. Also man muss so.
Auch nicht. Warum äh was willst du mit jemandem, die kein technisches Flair hat?
Ja, es ist schon.
Inner NGO. Ja? So, ich gucke mal in Duden.
Technisches äh Charisma.
Eine einen Menschen oder eine Sache umgeben, der als positiv angenehm empfundene, persönliche Note.
Und ein A vielleicht meinen sie eher diesen Begriff, feiner Instinkt und Gespür.
Besonders schweizerisch, sonst selten, steht im Duden. Ah,
Also sie meinen okay, sie meinen einen Feininstinkt für Technik. Ein feines Gespür für Technik. Okay.
Feines Gespür für Technik. Da ja.
Okay, dann macht's Sinn. Dann macht's Sinn. Ja, geil, haben wir was gelernt über die Schweiz. Besonders schweizerisch ist sonst selten.
Ja, super, alles klar, Kirre, macht Sinn. Wollen wir auch. Wir wollen auch feines, feines, feinen Instinkt und und Gespür haben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Sind wir für die Woche durch.
Genau. Wir bedanken uns allen mit äh Feingengespür für Podcasts für das Hören äh äh desselben. Und ähm ja, das war's heute.
Ganz einfach, mehr gibt's nicht. Müsst ihr nächste Woche wiederkommen.
Ist ja nicht so wiederkommen. Genau. Tschau, tschau.